[Musique]
maintenant, nous recevons des cadeaux qui ne
portent pas de masques faciaux pour réellement arrêter maintenant nous
n'avons pas tellement de courage ou pas aux
cordons mobiles que nous arrivons là-bas pour
comprendre pourquoi ils devraient avoir des
masques faciaux et ils obtiennent horriblement
le  fixer la masse là-bas
[Musique]
combien de place madame une matzo et des idées
ni rien sur une épaisseur c'était le
Connecticut sont mes enfants mais ça va
faire un feu on enregistre toujours ce que dans
certains cas maintenant on voit des femmes je suis un
groupe vulnérable  tapez les enfants
ainsi nous les arrêterons et veillerons à ce
que nous réduisions la population est
impliqué
[Musique]
vous